crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though or I encyclia soccer
star JUCO above ground crew goes better
than most Jay Larson self-diagnose go
download this week last week here we go
again [ __ ] the crab feast
yeah welcome back to the crab feast
y'all know the Tuesday another crowd for
use for their hands on another too good
to see you James sickle-cell good to be
here with it I said a sickle I'm like
let's see if we can get the fastest of
all time basic we big you'll really
quick tug and then you went all over the
goddamn the world's could I go you know
chaos in common here Jay Larson comic
com Jay Larson comedy on all social
media big thank you to everyone that
came out to meltdown last night I
appreciate you guys coming out great
house great show you guys rock bells I
will now be in Dublin coming up this
weekend please come out it's going to be
great I've been promoting it so you know
it if you're coming and then London the
week after that can't wait for that and
then after the next thing I'll be back
i'm going to chill out with the kids and
my in-laws will be in town and then the
comedy store in the 16th crab feast
comm.restore show yo Michael cost is
gonna be on the show Sklar brothers
gonna be on that show looking forward to
it and I'm just looking forward to being
here with you sickle I'm so looking
forward to the you looking forward to
stop by Ryan Sickler on Twitter
Instagram and Facebook Ryan Sickler calm
as Jay just said Tuesday August
sixteenth tickets by the way are only
five bucks we're gonna have some other
comedians on the window that will be
your favorite yeah they're only five
dollars we actually have quite a bit of
shows to tell you about very you can
hear the excitement on voice feast
company's common easy on first LA pod
fest here in Los Angeles September 23 to
25th there will be a live stream in
every room so if you can't come the
festival you can still get all the
podcast they'll be archived on the
website and remain for 30 days so you
have time to watch whatever you want Jay
and i'll also be on separately on panels
and we're gonna be doing the crap he's
there yeah don't lie there you go there
you go Jay just found out everybody ah
see it see what listening to the intro
does we put that in the counter me ah
price a live stream for the tire weekend
is 25 bucks but if you use our coupon
code you'll get five bucks off so you
get it for twenty bucks if you go to LA
pod fest that's it thanks man le pod
fest doc
um first live stream and our code crab
feast for the disc crab feast or now the
dates we've added some cities to our
crab feast stand-up tour which want to
be clear about that by the way they
stand up or stay alive podcast but you
you know come since do some stand-up
something you did that's give him the
date sickle October 21st will be in
Chicago coming to Chicago 20 seconds st.
to a little 20 seconds st. Louis October
26 if you're going to san francisco you
seeing you up there at the punchline and
over 27 sac town sacramento coming up
your way Toby 28 who's October toy a
Denver you ask it I mean we gotta set
that up but that'd be nice look will
look for inking Denver we're looking for
a venue trying to make that happen
looking for a venue in Denver uh hook us
up hit us up hook us up we'll come out
and do a share for you to November sixth
Jays hotel to laugh Boston november six
november eighth carolines on broadway
sound down south near airlines in New
York City November night rolling on down
into Philadelphia wheels the soul what's
up November 10th drafthouse comedy in DC
on the next year done see yes the
arlington drafthouse those guys bought a
another venue so there's one in DC this
is the DC drafthouse comedy and November
11th confirmed Baltimore coming to
Baltimore upset it probably be telling
you tickets for all shows will be on
Ryan Sickler calm and the crab feast
calm we're still waiting for clubs it is
with all the links but they will be
there and will be reminding you amazon
again always thank you so much premium
eps the facebook fan page by the way go
what would you do to it request it put
the [ __ ] TV follow follow go follow
the Deaf big because I all done what's
all that information and you're like is
it I can't remember their website
because they don't say it enough
facebook fan page will have all our tour
info too and if we do get to add any
cities Denver the info will be a
dated there and speaking of getting
updated get updated with your wardrobe
come on man get up there updated with a
lot of stuff being Emily your group man
we got the inside scoop on where to get
the latest tech gadgets fashions and de
corps for your lifestyle it's all
available touch of modern calm where you
can find it all with the best prices on
the web touch of modern calm connects
directly with top designers they have
timeless and unique products each item
hand selected to grab your attention all
the best prices online anywhere
guaranteed guaranteed man guaranteed I
am a daily viewer often purchaser at
touch of modern calm don't tell her eyes
bosses the please touch of modern scours
the globe for unique design focus
products to elevate your style
jaw-dropping tech gadgets and gear sleek
iphone cases and accessories new and
vintage watches that's what but you'll
be blown away by the way I mean liber I
can't even get his mouth you laugh you
will be you'll be blown away by the rock
collection loads of new sales literally
launched every day touch of modern calm
is the one website discover and improve
your lifestyle on a single click right
now you can get immediate access to
those deals when you sign up a touch of
modern calm that's touch of modern calm
do it today because tomorrow to be
different you know what's not different
this week's guest you might remember him
last week y'all imagine just kidding
relax but we have had him on before long
term comedy friend of both long term I
met him like when he was 19 long term
long term play please welcome back to
the crappy mr. new music how should I
have that as my stage and anything that
were you're implying dick is too boring
Nick and Yusef combined for nghiep he
got really mail he got really excited
new Q so that's although my I'm to I'm
to Middle Eastern ethnic to have that
mean ook yes whoever like that's a lame
joke though I go what he's doing but or
against imagine like where I could never
fly anywhere anywhere with that name
they like you
beb poor son after pain ever Duke Yusef
yeah this is your middle name is Isis
all right you can definitely gonna have
to come with us what is your real name
you have us no no it's uh Sammy Sammy
yeah s am I to it's my dad's name is his
name is Sam cuz i say i'm usually people
nicholas Sammy Nick Nicholas is my
birthday with no H it so may have a
weird name nikolaos the whole feel like
how can it sound American nickel nickel
alas I don't get why there's no H though
like a I never questioned it growing up
as an adult people if I ever have to
give my phone and like no age huh I've
heard that a hundred times I'm like our
did they [ __ ] up like what like did
ellis island just like throw it off the
thing or like wait do your parents born
here no no they were born in lebanon
another were they moved to the united
states of america move lucky lucky they
didn't again huh yeah dude 11 on me dude
all the all the stories I've ever heard
of them growing up there and like um and
what they what it took for them to move
here is just like you just appreciate
the [ __ ] out of living in America and
then I went and visited once did I did
yeah family there yeah I my mom's side
of the family so like it was one of
those things where you don't want to go
um I have to like to take this thing out
and sit back because I keep doing this
like healing a set aside so um it was
summer of 7th grade and like I just I
just made all these all these friends
right to just get to junior high and
you're like and I was a good level grade
was a sweet spot for me to it wasn't
work all clicked and everything was just
funny and fun yeah i mean it that was a
little freer yeah yeah I get it a little
more yeah like I could take electives
now screw you like I'm my own man it was
like that kinda thing so I took an art
class like I was like am free I'm an
adult making decisions yeah i made like
some new friends and stuff give me a
flattop know what was the what was the
haircut back then it was a step cut not
the flat was what's the steps so you
would shave the sides in the back and
then you leave like most of it like up
top
you grow it out you parted down the
middle ring nineties so it would like go
over the shave parts on the side like
come as you are yeah yeah uh whatwhat's
the haircut now that let you know how
like dudes have that top knot thing
where they'd shave the sides the back
and tie it imagines that but just not
tied out you leave it long that was a
very grungy now you're told yeah so r
almond now I was taller yeah I was at
one of the tolerance in school but it
was like I was I didn't know how to
carry myself I was not very popular
awkward as I was awkward as a loser it's
it's like everybody not everybody like
had more than probably probably most
everybody but I just wasn't that popular
but I felt like the cat made some like
made some new friends and it took some
work so I was just like I accomplished
something I want to hang out with these
friends in the summer really build on
this yeah dude and then my mom was like
there ya go 11 ah um Nikolai relax oh
good even worse my parents didn't call
me Nicholas or Nick so what they call
you the nickname the know uh sorta but
like there's a lot of French influence
in Lebanon they they colonized it you
know years back so you grew up there
learning arabic french english so there
was just like french in the slang in the
language so in France I guess Nicholas
would be would be Nicola be cold nika
did imagine being a 12 year old boy and
then your mom you'll industry nicola i
think is good girls just feminine
balance I thought we were friends I know
you're not my mom anymore David it was
the worst I had to like and that's kind
of when it started hit was like middle
school were you know a little bit
testosterone come Julius I'm a gardener
got my first few hairs so a name like
that all of a sudden you're getting made
fun of yeah and I'm like I to train my
mom I'm like if you call me anything but
Nick for the boyfriend I would've I'm
never coming home again so like it took
her and after a while she like Nick Nick
Nick Nick and I was like that's right
damn it
what does make her if you can i'll see
later you know those where they strict I
feel like later Middle Eastern parents
would be strict I mean they're like
they're they like we're in [ __ ] us
[ __ ] it right um they were a little bi
mean they were kinda strict but not too
strict you know they they they
definitely had rules you know like their
worker fees I can just run while do it
wrong they were strict on like you got
into your homework before anything else
and um they were very like they would
kind of monitor who my friends were cuz
they just like didn't didn't grow up in
America they didn't know like what kids
were wide of certain people like seemed
kind of like suspicious-looking because
they were like dressed kinda like punk
rock or whatever they didn't know what
that meant they were just like people
are crazy you know you can hang out with
them and they could have a perfectly
good kids you know a lot of war and they
and my mom was like a stay-at-home mom
up until like late middle school early
high school we kind of could like walk
to and from school and then she started
working but she just sit at home watch
like the local news and Oprah so she
thought like at any at any point my son
is gonna die from my fangs in a killer
bees like those are gonna kill you know
like he's not gonna go and if killer
bees don't take him out Marilyn Manson's
gonna convert him brain to Satanism yeah
so she was just like being fed all this
info so they were like a little more
strict because of things like that um
and 7th grade rolls around I get a
little bit more [ __ ] wiggle room [ __ ]
and then they're like you're where were
you worried from from Lebanon no are you
so around here Ali well here I I grew up
in la crescenta well ok you know that it
yep um it's uh de quiet middle-class
suburb you know like nothing special
didn't it could have meant Ridge no next
door to that lokmanyatilak me right um
so I was envy I gotta be specific
because either people have no idea or
they think it's somewhere else set up
off the is that the two off the tune the
210 yeah right there the twos when the
best I way down your arm web series that
you did with Rory and Al you shot in
montrose at the City Hall coffee shop
which I've gone to a million times
growing I mean that holy I mean cuz
that's like right at the top of Glendale
then montrose and then I lombriz right
up there
right or I know what's the other one
that sounds like um altadena alta dena
pasadena yeah there's an answer yeah la
kenyatta flintridge right yeah so yeah I
love that strip home honolulu at the old
bowling alley over there that yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] still still looks like
it's like 1950 inside and it's never
open to the public we would want only
private parties all and so we were
convinced the mob ran a show we elected
the mob runs that bowling alley and we
had no idea was only six lanes over this
is that many yeah maybe for thing is for
we do we've all my life it's been ever
so long never oh wow it's open I've been
in there oh yeah but they don't open the
public that you come bowling you can
only do like birthday parties and stuff
like that no way so you never even set
foot a six-lane never set foot um but
yeah it's a cool little acronis a little
my duty winch of mantras um so yeah
seventh grade all I want to do is hang
out in la crescenta montrose ride BMX
bikes and just chill and my mom and dad
were like we're going to Lebanon you
gotta visit the family got to go back to
the to the roots of motherland and see
I'm like I don't motherland is right
here dude it's hanging out the arcade
going to mcdonalds learning a bunnyhop
of a curb that's the new motherland I'm
gonna marry I have a very serious ly
right so I had little say in the matter
turns out course when you're 12 you
can't be like one standing here alone
I'll guard the fort get a job or
whatever so we got go to Lebanon and I'm
just like oh they stay what it was a
family trip they did I sent you over to
visit family no no it was it was me my
mom and my brothers younger by two years
he didn't care either way girls were
gone my dad had to work so he's like
I'll come later you know like a few
weeks n so wait how long did you go for
we went for most of the summer that was
that was my major issue it was the only
vacation we had ever taken up until then
and since then like we weren't like a
vacation family was at that point I
think we don't have a cage my mom just
flew how many hours with two [ __ ]
kids 12 and 10 X 12 depends got to be a
can of corn compared to like now or 14
hours no no no if we were a nightmare
I was a nightmare kid like I was like
I'm I was a troublemaker I sucked and
then two boys two years apart all you're
doing is fighting fighting yeah and if I
was bored for more than 11 seconds I'll
just pick on my brother just punch of
the journey to respond yeah I wonder
what happens if I flick him in the
eyeball and then I would find out
shortly thereafter and my mom shut up so
we get there and I'm just like this is
miserable all the whole summer I'm gonna
be spending in this stupid country yeah
I didn't know about her you know and
we're hanging out in the city and Beirut
is X feral cats all over the place like
it's not pretty but not downtown Beirut
is like the streets are just narrow look
like downtown Bay exactly haha every
time Sebastian would tell that joke I
was like he's not wrong like that's what
downtown Beirut it looks like a war it
just ended because award did just end
like yeah years ago and they had really
like rebuilt the place you're walking
down the street and like you'll see an
apartment building like that has a
couple like bullet holes that were never
just like fixed you know so you're
looking and you're like what is that and
then one of the local like kids 11
ministries like oh that's those are you
know bullets from like the war or
whatever and I'm like how like how do
they not fix that I middle-class suburb
in LA you just if you don't see every
Panthro to show ya hear don't worry
about that really sturdy right right
there's none of that here this know like
war and fighting and like bulletin I
mean so it not even really registered
that no I was just like this stupid
bullet holes is not as fun as what I
could be having is walking around
hanging around the city and then my mom
was like we're going down to like the
villages in southern Lebanon and we're
gonna like hang out there you have some
family down there and we're like
whatever so we're like driving down
there felt like a nine to go there at
this point he was there at that point so
it felt like a nine-hour drive us right
now and half Lebanon it's very small
it's like you could fit a few of them in
California or something so we're driving
down there and then my mom goes okay
we're coming up to a checkpoint pretend
like you're sleeping only what's a
checkpoint and yeah chandi mom yeah yeah
shady
that's pricey I wanna know why is she
smart because you know something's up
yes she grew up there she knows with the
you know like you're living in in in an
area where like neighboring countries
and people don't get along like there's
just that it's a different set of rules
you know we're Americans yeah we
everybody hates we're like kind of
dressed American we speak English you
know so she's like it's just better if
you pretend you're sleeping they're
gonna talk to you and like if you
accidentally say something in English
all this and then have questions or like
deal we pretend we're sleeping and like
to the kind of corner why you just seem
like pull up to like this checkpoint
with like guys in full-on military
outfits with machines and like this like
this giant trucks and we're just what is
it and we're coming scared Anakin
they're speaking in Arabic they're
looking at passports and then they just
let us go it was very brief like all
right that was what was that all about
now hold those like what's the terrain
like train is like ah I mean you have
paved road it was like a is a dirt but
mostly mostly paved uh but not like well
houses or you looking at like you
looking like hills is a green is it a
lush trees it's like daughter it's a
greenish brown not really like a lot of
not a lot of houses is kind of a
desolate like have you ever driven if
you've ever driven down like uh into
Baja California past Tijuana mm like
that kind of thing um it's it just goes
like a two-lane highway and you're
seeing like hills that are greenish
brown not a lot of buildings on it I
felt desert ish but not really I had a
buddy who's from Iran and he was he was
grew up in Iran yeah and he was an older
dude and so I would make fun of all time
I'm like you know it's a desert man it's
like where you grew up he's like it's
[ __ ] not like the dinner run you
[ __ ] [ __ ] green everywhere right
yeah this was not like that no it did it
just didn't feel it felt just like
rundown like the country just felt like
it had just been through so much [ __ ]
and was just like leave us alone for a
while your little brother felt like yeah
yeah yeah I was I declared a civil war
on the house and I and my brother was
like the losing so
I was just like just leave us alone let
the bruises heal uh and that's what the
how that country fell in like the mid
nineties you know like 94 any whatever
was um it just felt that way and I
didn't I didn't know it at the time I
was just like get me out of here I want
to do something fun and we're in this
village and like there's like they felt
kind of felt like you know Adobe huts
like a lot of them somewhere big some
are nicer than others plumbing not some
didn't have windows are just kind of
open air you know and we're sitting
there like there's like cows and goats
you know walking by and I'd never seen
that before me you just go pet those
like yeah so once those house owns them
goats would go buy something walking in
man yeah man you know couple cows would
go by and then the biggest tank I've
ever seen in my life would go by I'm my
serious yeah dude I'm like what the [ __ ]
is that and the kid that like one of his
a live there without batting an eye is
like oh yeah they go by like usually uh
in the mornings and evenings just to
check up on stuff and like to check up
on what like what are they checking up
on is and they they're just like it's
just part of life like I just make sure
everything's fine i'm like [ __ ] this is
amazing what you it's like to if you're
just born yeah do it it's not well it's
their version of like you know in the
old cities like in the 1800s and the
east coast when like the police movie
walking through the neighborhood look
like town ya ain't like putting up the
gaslamp the right hey yeah and it wasn't
even I found out a Lebanese tank it was
an Israeli tank and because at the time
is Israel had like the southern border
of Lebanon occupied because they were
there was all this like fighting going
on between the southern border and their
northern border so they had like had it
kind of like controlled to prevent
people from lobbying you know mortar
rounds and missile whatever so we're
just like this is weird man like you
guys just live life like this and there
they like yeah it's not really a big
deal nothing really happens and we're
like okay we go out go go go about our
day patent some goats and like trying to
catch little like frogs and little ponds
and stuff and then night time rolls
around and we're like all getting ready
to go to sleep and my brother and I kind
of sitting there like talking we just
here like these noises in the distance
and we're like we're like mom what is
that we're all sleeping in the same room
and uh I was like oh no nothing nothing
but there was the way she said nothing
was like that was too fast for it to
really mean we knew like that's
something what is it she's like it's
nothing is just like I I don't know it's
just nothing just those are the noises
you hear I hear sometimes we're on the
middle of nowhere um just go to bed i'll
tell you tomorrow like if you were in in
germany in 1940 you hears a noise right
yeah uh or like all right whatever and
then we get up the next and run back to
the city and we were like hey whatever
those noises what were they and she's
like oh those are just uh people the way
she like try to dress it up check well
Lebanon Israel just like having a little
bit of a disagreement so they were kind
of just like fighting a little bit I'm
just like I'm not a [ __ ] I've seen GI
Joe yeah I know the [ __ ] going on you
mean they're blotting bombs at each
other and then we're getting mad at her
like you brought us down here almost got
us killed and then she kinda like laughs
knowing that you had the dopest story to
go back to the stage right uh yeah and
uh and we get back to the city and then
like we wrap up the trip and get home
and I had like a week of summer left and
I try to pack as much as I could in it
which didn't work and i was like pissed
at my parents up until probably like
late high school when you not like AG
everyday but like every time I you know
thought about that trip like you have
been there it's dumb by then I was like
more appreciative of like having been
dragged to a different part of the world
to see how people live you know [ __ ] you
see if Richard Linkletter had written
your story right you woulda liked had
cousins that took you like this swimming
hole would be like this Israeli girl
there and it's a friend saw boob and
you'd really make out you like I pen
pals with her till high school and I did
birth right now I wish did I wish the
problem was my moms too busy [ __ ]
blocking the entire time oh [ __ ] here go
to bed you're gonna get it were there
any girls your age that were over there
at all or there was one that doesn't
lived above my we stayed with my
grandparents my mom's parents in in
Beirut and above them was apparently
this girl that I like
when I was like two or something before
we moved here um like I got a hit it off
with him like hit off some one or two
you know like and like oh you guys all
just hang out together and they're like
she's really pretty you gotta meet you
gotta mean are you got a mean or where
we go when we go and I'll all right so
I'm like all right well they hyped her
up for you they did I mean when I'm when
when my daughter and my son are old
enough I'm gonna do exactly that and do
like what your dad did you know i mean
like rise dad used to embarrass the [ __ ]
off from and i'm gonna be like yeah come
over here yeah because i'm gonna be
telling me to go talk to that girl right
now you're gonna regret the rel you shut
your mouth get over there and go off the
buyer slice of pizza like that's on the
here's here here's twenty bucks go buy
us lace-up eat the one that's that
really stuck with me was um we had this
old a station wagon it was a 77 dodge
aspen limited edition wood panel like
tinted windows but the would you settle
down a limited edition on Election wagon
was a less why I'm saying there was no
work there was no wood paneling
non-limited rise limb I'm not living
mopar we had none limited yes so uh you
had an unlimited was the paneling there
was it wasn't good um just primer spots
uh we're in Ocean City Maryland we are
in gridlock traffic on coastal highway
bumper-to-bumper like the PCH you know
it's stuck but it's all touristy and
there's a car of like I'm seventh grade
no uh ninth grade carload of girls like
maybe senior week right here next week
I'm just yeah i mean i'm drooling I'm
looking I'm like ah you know and then my
I had the power steering that if you
touch do you know the car but remember
that old-school power steering and the
windows were early electric and I just
here I see this window go down like and
I'm just just like panting and it's so
loud cuz he had the air on that the
[ __ ] girls look over and he's like
hey girls this was son Ryan Rob Baghdad
no I just they were laughing he just
kept [ __ ] on me and [ __ ] ago me like
what do you think I'm slumping out of
kicking his see like they're like well
he seems angry and he's sweating a lot
doesn't we think
I'm trying to roll the window up he's
got a locked up there like I did that
ever work though did he ever do that and
you actually were able to strike up it
was like an actual icebreaker he would
do it like if we went to though it
wasn't even an icebreaker sometimes was
just funny to embarrass you know I mean
like you just want to go on so like we
would go to Oriole games he's got three
kids so we're sitting in the upper deck
and he'd see a girl wick but it was
always older girls like that would get
it and you know wouldn't mind like
clowning around he like hey good look
this he did it at the beastie boys run
DMC concert I'll never forget it he and
another friend's dad took us to see
together forever back on the Beastie
Boys were licensed to ill with girls and
birdcages and [ __ ] yeah and this row of
girls is right behind us at the cap
center and he just turns around it
doesn't write things like hey girls my
son Ryan what do you think I'm like what
do you stopped and I'm like so [ __ ]
pissed did that like it made me laugh so
hard it just didn't during it no God I
want the guys I'm I so of course I was
like oh no they had to make you better
with girls as an adult where your life
there's no rejection like what how
uncomfortable could I feel when growing
up all I felt was that uh before we go
any further we're here with Nick you
said I won't ever tell everybody i know
well this guy just don't even don't know
what to talk about lady goes on and on
about this lebanon so yeah let's uh what
will come back to the girl that they
were trying to hype up for you over
there stop but why don't you tell
everyone where they can find you on
twitter your album all that stuff
promote it I am I did just blow right by
this the first time we've ever done this
this deep into a seagull I mean it
support 45 minutes in right well cuz in
my head you're like we already did the
intro maybe that's what I thought but
you didn't say anything there yeah
that's true tell um yeah I just broke
the [ __ ] rules there's no rules I
have uh I just released a new album on
May 27th it's been off for a little bit
called it's called 1982 perfect he has a
gyros born and
a lot of the material on there's kind of
like around that sort of like you're
around that age bracket if you're born
around those years if you you know like
I just talked about a lot of that sort
of stuff but if you're older it doesn't
matter because I mean when I met you you
were I think 18 and and like my friend
who was with me at the time was like 32
and would like do that kid is hilarious
on my guys [ __ ] annoying 18 year old
is it nobody like you do political humor
then I mean like you're like an
intelligent you were older than 18 you
know I mean mentally yeah I guess
mentally went to Beirut metal season
yeah they're yeah I throw you right up
uh I also had no life experience I'm
like I go so did topical material right
I actually cared about politics in time
oh is this your second now my first a
second I'll second out way better on the
first do not get the first which if you
listen to the first time I was on here
I'd be plugging the first album it was
like were you yeah when I came on Owen
I'm starting to see a pattern yeah maybe
they're right now so yeah that is
available you can buy it on iTunes I
would prefer that route or but if you
know you know whatever people don't
budge anymore stream it on Spotify Apple
music amazon google play anywhere where
you can stream music and comedy it's
available there there'll be a vinyl run
at the end of summer early fall on a
special thing records all of that
information can be found on my website
Nikki Yousef calm and you can follow me
on Twitter Instagram and Facebook have a
comedy page all of that is n IC kyou SS
e f 2 s's 2 s's one and always english i
always write it wrong i go 1 s 2 f's my
yeah most people that do it that way no
way CH 2 s's i know it's all this is so
many to so many weird things going on
with my name apparently as i'm finding
out but yeah so that's all that info and
then um all right this comes out next
week this will be out on the second so
26 26 06 oh yeah yeah we're still or not
at the end of july so um
if you live in the fine city of
Philadelphia i'll be at the helium
comedy club august 18 through 20th and
if you live in the fine city of tampa
florida i'll be at the tampa improv
august twenty fifths will 25th through
the 27th great ref fees will be at
helium in philly november nine pm and
we're not coming up behind Nick yousa he
has done that helium I've never I've
never done it we haven't either route I
haven't been to Philly in like I only
went there once ever and it was we were
driving through we didn't use the road
trip like all the time like yeah i mean
my friend I remember like he's really
doing it used to like drive to like
concerts all the time with people oh
yeah oh my god man Yousef is such like a
traveler yeah when I started to just be
like I was like I gotta live more life
so I can have like stuff talk about and
stand up but my one time ever being in
philly i was like visiting me and my
buddy were in maryland and we were like
hey let's go up to New York and we
passed through philly and I was like
dude I've never had a philly cheesesteak
is like my body lives in Philly let's
stop and we stopped it there's a diff
two famous ones across you from each
other he's like well these are the two
like most famous ones so you just pick
one of these I'm like when you pick I'm
like we're eating boom oh do you I'm not
an American do you hate America did you
can do with him uh and was a clear cut
it was actually really close I cuz i
just i mean louie knows and knows pat
pat that's right there was no break in
between I like I finished one and as I
was like finishing last night like I was
like walking across the street to the
other place and I my of this i ordered
the same exact thing same exact way
aight it i'm like i can't pick one of
those were really close so the friend
goes well you know the locals prefer
jim's that's over on South Street I'm
like why are we not in the car heading
the gym so why are we still talking
about did you not and not being at jims
and he's like are you serious I'm like
let's go oh I'm 22 my metabolism to the
roof nothing can stop me so we drive
down there and I ate another 53 foot
long filling
AM and then drove to New York and then
the trash when Jim's did win actually
that's good enough I have November night
helium-filled yeah dr how did you get
them how did I get him I got him um I
think with onions and Wiz I did it the
big of the cheese was I'm like whatever
straight up cheese was no other cheese
no other cheese yeah they mix it in with
or these put on the role to put on the
role and then like salt and pepper and
then whiz I just went by South Philly
truck that comes around here I'm a guy
you stick shake before and they were
like do the Wiz do the Wiz and I'm like
I don't want to do the fun ways I've had
the words before I like it first but
after its it seeps into everything it's
like soup you know what I mean I just
put me some problem since what I did
after trying the Wiz I'm Leah no more I
got it I only want steak and cheese one
way mushrooms and onions fambam and
white American cheese and I want this is
what I want because I made him for five
years growing up when I worked at a
pizza joint it's perfect when it on the
grill I want the cheese laid over the
meat so it's melting as its melting then
I want you to take the meat from
underneath and slip it on top and mix
all the cheese in and then drop it in
the role I like I'm with you my second
alternative is straight-up steak and
cheese uh-huh in the role mayonnaise and
pickles and then boom what a lot of
mayonnaise guy on it on a cheesesteak I
like it I like it just whispered on it
you know not just what male like a
separate just adjust uh yeah like yeah
like a look Oh perfect hey man let me
get that shaking cheese mushroom ready
to get up for that may I whatever i also
have yelled at
oh man previous Cubs I don't like to
imagine that that's us on the screen you
know they go spicy medium or not would
you like Mayo heavy light with her Oh
stick a whisper and then there's maybe a
speaker on the string that just goes man
all right so Jim's was the winner huh
widow knell for your steak and cheese
the loser was the toilet that I clogged
and you hit single cell right there man
oh man it up at it was very [ __ ]
cheese yeah there was a serious Apollo
my soul thanks for letting us crash here
and I'm really sorry about you I just
had never been to Philly in the hole man
we're just taking cheese go to in LA do
you have one I literally and this is not
because I just told us I had one on the
way here at this place called Harvey's
hard i'm like motor i know what i'm
talking about it says it on the sign
yeah yeah don't ever that's no bueno now
it's right on the corner yeah I know
exactly talking about I just was in I
was I was really hungry and I'm like
that sounds great right now and now I
know never to go the only place i'll go
is booze yeah yeah I'll of booze I got
one other than booze and get South
Philly truck is pretty song all right
there's another place in like Westwood
that does like paps and philly cheese
like it's a it's a Philly place and I've
had one there which wasn't bad but booze
is the best and then there's a place on
the west side on Lincoln called the
Great Western hoagie yeah okay and you
order it a window I'm never going out of
state here's a deal you know blue and
white I know exactly it's got cage on it
yeah it's a carnival [ __ ] up in there
looks like you're selling carnival
tickets on lincoln right yeah that
that's a good one I've been there
where's the deal every one of their
steak and cheese comes no matter what
with onions and red sauce tomato sauce
yeah and so I always be like hey no red
sauce can you add mushrooms and like yep
and I go can you mix that cheese in like
yeah they get so annoyed and they don't
have fries or anything it's just that
maybe meatball subs and like chips so
you can't get fries and a coke seriously
miss sub shops that's one Marilyn had a
lot of good sub shops I don't you know
what I mean like it would say no he
doesn't now he grew up in la crescenta
rich I'm locked me out of lit rich
there's not a lot of subs not out here
in general there aren't as pizza and
subs you would even that would even be a
feature like so oh you know what else
who has a really good cheese steak uh oh
what's the joint right there in culver
city capriotti's capriotti's is a really
good cheese steak tions gonna go they
sure do and then this one was closer
they're legit they [ __ ] they
appreciate tip them they ring a bell and
yell beer money and it's it's it's good
it's what the amorosa what if you tipped
and then you realize I gotta put three
but let me get to those back back um are
they gonna back let's get biscuit back
tell story your parents are hyping this
girl up I don't think this is going
anywhere it's not yes not a route yeah
nothing nothing really happens except
that like I see her now as a as a 12 13
year old and she was like ugly Sam
picture gonna cover Nat Geo member that
chick or the green-eyed yeah no no this
girl had what every what any American
kid would like joke about a Middle
Eastern girl having she had like a light
mustache and Harry was just a whisper of
a month always she had her life in her
up right I mean they would be monsters
if they said yes she's I was like mom
she has a whisper stash if this is like
everybody hates chris but there you like
mom looking at most i'd like could be
worse look at this chicken she got this
little beard got like lamb chop yeah
yeah yeah i like a bird's nest to get
did you have cut was there anyone your
age there you could relate to cousins or
you want visited family was you know was
there anyone to show you the ropes let
me show you this [ __ ] we do there was
this kid that like lived on the street
who like it was like yeah let's go look
around the corner and all he wanted to
do was like throw rocks at stray cat
like man what is with this place yeah do
people not live normal like this girls
grown a mustache and has leg hair and
doesn't know to shave it and then this
kids like favorite pastime is like
throwing rocks at stray cats I gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here uh man she said she
all she did
summer was follow me around and want to
hang out with me and that they were
hyping you up to I apparently and she
was like have you have you ever heard of
uh Michael Jackson I like yeah what the
[ __ ] what kind of like they'd just
gotten Michael Jackson then just gotten
Metallica they had just gotten all the
stuff is just trying to impress me I'm
like I live in a first-world nation get
away from me uh-uh I didn't say that but
I acted though I thought that but
Congress she ugly but not your right
into which she ugly she was but then
later in life you uh had some good luck
with ladies later you know happen to her
later in life I asked about her a couple
years ago we were a girl that little ha
right uh she goes oh she was in one of
your favorite movies from dusk till dawn
I was like no no uh she ended up
becoming a [ __ ] prostitute oh and she
flies yet flies to Saudi Arabia and
please like a high dollar escort yes
sleeps with so it is Luis and I was like
wait so she end up getting good-looking
my moms like yeah yeah so that was that
was her trajectory yeah apparently did
get better looking them wow that's crazy
but who knows man the did you know
exotic eccentric billionaire that that
lies are in probably likes hairy women
it might be the head he would hurt her
prostitute named was like whispers ish
bring me whisper real quick yeah it was
per session here um but I did get better
with the girl yeah let's talk about it
um I I was having this conversation
actually with Ari Shaffir like a chaffer
ya era Schaeffer is quick on um who's
just like you hundred threesomes even
happen and I was like I had one and took
what like he couldn't he couldn't
believe it is like had it happened I'm
like dude like every other threesome
story I'd ever heard they just start
happening like you don't plant you can't
plan like I'm gonna sleep with her and
her you're just like hanging out a party
or something and talking in the next
thing I like wait a minute so that's
exactly what happened the when I had one
and this is not like a bragging
threesome story it's weird one so I'm in
San Francisco with my buddy and we're at
this party and like we're at a party
with all these friends he went to
college with who were like these silicon
valley types and he's like dude I'm
telling you right now we're gonna go
this party there's gonna be no girls
these are all like computer guys they
don't even know women like the room
afraid of them and they created they
built one but yeah right the only woman
they know has a serial number on her Oh
sound like I mean that's probably gonna
be a few is like well they're not gonna
be pretty I'm like we'll see what
happens so we never know what a girl can
turn into okay yeah exactly uh they
disordered this one from Saudi okay so
we're hanging out an hour goes by
nothing and like this I'm like what
about that girl she's dating a guy all
right and then some money girl comes in
who's like how old you know I'm like 25
26 um so this girl comes in and I was
like whoo she's cute and she's like half
Korean like half Irish or something
she's a kind of like a little exotic but
like cute and she could have been cute
her just because we're surrounded by
like computer nerd guys or one dude was
dressed like the Undertaker like it was
he just I don't know like he had like a
good man he look like he went from a D&D
basement like just act just finished a
game dungeon dragons now gonna go to
this party and go right back to the game
like that's what he look like long
trench coat big adventurer hat you know
had the Hat he would really did leave
the hair I had kind of long yeah long
hair that was like tied back I mean he
just looked like like if the Undertaker
had like a nerdy brother it was done
today whatever yeah uh that guy stole
his drinking picked him up by the throat
slammed him down and then lightning came
out of nowhere haha her to goddamn arm
with him around the whole [ __ ] party
right weird and the best part though is
he was the only dude with a chick and
I'm like is that considered cool in this
world like the wood that that guys like
home motif and he had a girl and then
that Korean Irish girl comes in like
she's I'm like I'm going right for her
I'm gonna hit on her I'll show my friend
I'm gonna hook up with somebody lease
may
well you're already in advance or
because you're the comedian at the place
and everyone else is like dude does one
thing you know yeah but they all have
like money and [ __ ] some of those dudes
were like yeah forgot about that yeah I
have a model right I had like an
interesting unique job but they had uh
boring jobs but like few of them had a
couple million dollars so just where is
weird mix of people saw my I'm gonna go
talk to this girl and so I go up to her
we kind of you know start generic Bowl
chicana I'm from LA you live here uncle
San Francisco's fun blah blah blah that
I ate here earlier and he's going great
then this girl walks up who is I mean I
don't want to sound mean but like she um
looked like a female version of John
Turturro okay okay so not like all John
Turturro is not a looker you for duty
have that curly black hair yeah it's
kind of wavy okay and her face kind of
look like John Turturro she also was
that your opener hate anyone tell you
look like it I do want to see rounders
yeah um was the one he was in the Coen
brothers one he's in a box in the news
and I got four brother Otto right now
Big Lebowski so I'm you watch that in
what the night before those are good
yeah it's fantastic rate in it I want to
see a young boy i'm waiting to get a few
not derail you but he i just found out
cuz i saw that james gandolfini had an
EP credit on i was like what the hell is
that all about you know that's nice he
must been working on it and he was well
he was what i read was he supposed to be
to toro no way yeah like he was supposed
to that was the role and then he passed
and then to toro took the role hey Pat
why would he pass him that sounds like a
great role document wait what he passed
in 2013 all right expired i said i er um
i went right over me I ok I'll just yeah
oh so shoots out the whole thing over
yeah just rewind so i'm in san francisco
art um some talking to this girl and
then john turturro Cobra
like who's this chick and I kind of take
a little job too yeah is Jane turrets
which is call that are chained turturro
look uh uh uh so I didn't really like
register her first except I was just
like that's it is really not attractive
girls here like getting in the way of me
talking to this attractive girl what is
she doing and I kind of okay I ignore
can I go back and then she's still there
and then I kind of take a closer look
she's also like really short like
unusually short and then one of her legs
is shorter than the other cuz she liked
him step back i think it so she walk
with like kind of a limp I'm like I mean
did some is some [ __ ] with me right
now like why are they putting her here
I'm talking with the only pretty girl in
the room so I kind of sorta include her
because I could sense they may be know
each other mm-hmm so all three of us are
kind of talking but eighty percent of my
energies on the Korean Irish girl she
goes I got 20 on Jane yeah a bday to
hear a poop okay why it was right here
on the gridiron it's a polite 20 I
wanted to give her 10 I gave her 20 but
at this point you're still not a hundred
percent sure of those two know each
other yet treating it as if they may and
like let's yeah I'm being diplomatic
right i'm just playing it safe I don't
want to go like listen Jane take a hike
trying to get on this yeah it's Jan I'm
trying to hit on this girl that doesn't
have a physical defect all right aside
from the genetic one so the pretty girl
goes you know excuse me for a second I
gotta go like powder my nose whatever
she have something she walks off and the
second she walks off Jane turturro just
like like looks me in the eye and she
goes are you trying to [ __ ] that girl
like all serious as low as i was an as I
huh I don't know I just met her I don't
like are you guys friends she goes
she'll it like leans in and she goes
I've been trying to [ __ ] her for five
years and I'm like like all right let's
team up I got okay nothing will get here
the problem yeah awesome I was just like
dude what are you are you kidding right
now I first of all I can't tell if
you're a magical creature that like it I
know
even if you're here for real you know
have I imagined you yeah um so she goes
yeah I've been trying to [ __ ] her we've
known each other we've been friends I've
been trying to get in her pants for five
years and she goes and you're a real
good for ya she goes you seem to be
making headway and I go that way okay
because I'm just trying to put myself a
chance position I could do him I can't
hurry to him and she [ __ ] figures out
I mean cuz think about that she I'm
guessing this is my guest that the one
on one wasn't gonna happen no so she had
to figure out another way to get in that
[ __ ] door and she saw you making
which she calls that way and thought let
me see if I can't [ __ ] ride that wave
on in her budget vagina that's exactly
what she did while she goes arm we have
to try and [ __ ] her together like I I
kick this party went from but man there
are no girls here to away from no girls
to a girl trying to get me to [ __ ] a
girl with her I'm like yeah what is
going on here Mike are you joking right
now she's like she's like she kind of
suggested once as she sorta into girls
and would be open to get my notebook ok
that was July yeah 2008 yeah according
to my notes the motor modeled a runner
here yeah so I'm like look I i'm down to
try it i guess i've never been in this
situation but I'm like look you know her
better than I do so you lead I'm gonna
take your lead I'll just call then the
other thing right car was like yeah yeah
um The Undertaker was actually at the
time trying to revive a dead pigeon he
was casting a spell somewhere on the
other side of the party and feel it very
interesting um so she comes back and had
applied like a fresh coat of bright red
lipstick Oh which was that kind of this
weird sort of like a sickle mating call
type kind of
like who the [ __ ] wears bright red lips
and then the other go like [ __ ] chin
up awkward on that shorter leg yeah
Jesse grew three inches sure you're more
like Jane you got taller what happened
um and then I noticed it I was like this
is I gotta just say yeah the weirdest
start to a threesome I've ever heard
yeah and my new favorite no doubt yeah
oh god they're so I still don't know
what to do here I'm like you stole a t20
now get no no it's got to be 64 64 TS
exactly what I am out of it cuz I'm like
you got a teammate to think yeah I do
we're in this together she's my running
mate so I'm thinking like I gotta get I
gotta get like her interested like the
Korean cuz she was like sort of being
flirty but not enough you know so she
came back and then we started talking
about her lipstick I'm playing oh wow
you weren't wearing that earlier so I
thought thrown on its nice I'm like uh
and then the other girl like without
even being coy or anything she's like
she's like she's like yeah I probably
makes him want to make out with you and
I was like okay so this is the lead i'm
following like you're just gonna be
direct and i go home and just like
listen mother yeah and five minutes for
you to five again right yeah yeah yeah
you're my meal again [ __ ] do what I
right yeah give nipples yeah she's like
yeah also suck his dick I'm let go
everyone's eyes max I mean I I mean look
at her Jay a nap right that marks I'm
not really making it is that suck
talking to the Undertaker um so um I'm
like yeah um hahaha yeah wood and then
she goes like uh well then why are you
try who said that the Creator yeah and I
go alright and then I leave the Korean
Asia
what happens here you did so so I go all
right and then like I leaned in and just
like lightly kind of kissed her because
I whisper kiss yeah I gave her a whisper
um so as to not upset Jane turturro I
didn't want to just full-on makeout and
kind of sideline her you know I've
everyone's like sliding in between it to
ya exactly take a come help me uh body
slam this guy so I know where's your
buddy at this point now he's off talking
his friend could have been running
interference now Jam guys on a PPO is
he's really good about like he's like
yeah I'm you do you're saying I'm not
gonna even [ __ ] block or help or try and
ruin it by helping where I'm just I'm
out of here Jan just all right yeah so I
go I go we should I go would be funny of
all three of us made out like a
three-way make out does that ever happen
well I don't know so we actually try and
do it like we sit down okay do you have
to sit down his jan so sure yeah she
bring a ladder will you 63 64 and korean
irish is probably like 545 funny thing
jan is James like a solid two foot three
like she's really sure no but she's like
four or in the 4 or 10 she's pushing for
10 okay wow maybe five feet but it's
like she had the walk with my feet on
the on the good leg shut up yeah say
that's a good luck five feet on on the
good leg with uh with heels a long leg
he all right the good way good leg would
have a two inch heel the other leg would
have a four-inch the bouncer think so
yes she's just like is all messed up so
I go I lee i will try and move do it and
then it obviously doesn't work I don't
have you ever tried a three-way make out
there's no way to get you know so we're
like haha that was awkward and funny and
I go hey it's getting kind of late we
should like you know this party's
starting to die down and it was already
at like a flat line so it's at this
point people are like probably
so Natalie dare ya also Matata right
somic look why don't we all get out here
let go you know get some drinks like
hang out at one of your places like oh
I'm crashing with a friend I don't even
live here and then change it arose like
I live in [ __ ] like Berkeley or
oakland which should take the train it's
already four-thirty in the morning I'm
like that's out of the question like I
guess this what are we gonna do Korean
Irish goes oh yeah i live like six
blocks away my were with that
information min ago let's all go to your
pictures yeah totally the next morning
there's like this big street festival
thing that she kind of wanted to like
get up for she did work going to work
kind of her she's like honestly you guys
I can't hang out too late so we're gonna
have to go now and me and ginger like
yeah that's we want to go now to yeah
she's no idea we're both trying to like
occur at the same time yeah so we get in
a cab this is pre over like wait for a
cab it's now pushing 5am I like we gotta
go we got to go we get to the place
we're hanging out on her elephants are
coming LC goddamn instead of here if
these jugglers would get out of the way
get back in the circuit yeah get back in
your cage and breathe fire like you've
been hired to do so we get back there
and then we're all kind of sitting on
the bed and I sit in the middle and I
just I put how do you do this and I go I
put one hand on kind of each of them on
my kind of looks like put this being a
handsy and then I make out with the
Korean Irish girl and then Jane turturro
just like leaps like she just away from
pound she went from behind me to all of
a sudden she's on top of this girl like
trying to like kiss her neck while I'm
trying to make out there I'm like well
you move quick when you're horny like
she's like at the party drive your build
up yeah they got this chick is like
meeting this is it yeah and uh we kind
of all start like slowly taking our
clothes off and we just start like
making out and like I start going down
on the Korean Irish want to do as little
as possible with ginger and she's like
she's like oh should I get over here
like yeah whatever works just like an
engine yeah we were to get to where I go
get us a piece of beef for sandwiches
right back um so she's like she's being
more girl
civ than me i'm just like having a good
time like she's having a time are less
is her dream come true I mean shoes all
shoes like mostly focused on like
kissing her like she's looking she was
in love with her like she she jack I've
been done it was that sounds like I've
been trying to do this for a while and
then like um we start like [ __ ] who
me in the Korean Irish girl we had one
condom that she had had and then we were
having Santoro had a bag all right now
tuturro mad me tuturro was like I kid
the condom actually broke like it was a
shitty like she got it at a party cuz
like I think I have one somewhere it
broke thatís came out of a pinata I
think here I think so and uh and also
what the [ __ ] do we do now and then
everything just kinda started die now
she goes look it's getting kinda late
anyway and you know maybe maybe this was
just a sign which kind of just like wrap
it up and then change rear rear a pariah
I go where is a liquor store I'll go get
more she's like no no I really gotta get
to bed and then change her still trying
to like you know kiss and suck on her
tits until the seven she's like I think
we should probably the it's the you know
the buzz has been killed it is just it's
over now and then we both were just like
[ __ ] and then she just kind of lays back
ginger turn it looks at me and she goes
you can [ __ ] me without a condom my girl
I like you just need it from where we
can get it well let's be honest okay and
I mean if she is and does have a
disability and isn't you know that good
looking maybe she's not running getting
tail all the time you know I mean but
she's so like aggressive about it like
you gotta think she's getting laid still
something dudes are [ __ ] scumbag you
know I said yeah clearly long you know I
i mean i was able to disable girl i was
just teaming up with her old so we're
and I was like oh and then the Korean
Irish girl go she's like oh sex is that
economy gross I'm definitely out now
guys let's just let's just all go to bed
we had a little bit of fun with extra
mid well play around it's good and I was
like all right so then I go into the
bathroom and then
changer toro comes in after me and then
she goes like uh say how it sucks at
that to go down that way she's like you
sure you don't want to bend me over this
toilet and [ __ ] me anyway and I was like
listen all right I'll do it yeah and
then I just [ __ ] because I was still
like halfway up up on I could out my
plan was like exact well the trash can
was used to get her up onto the toilet
yet uh to take a few steps um and then I
had sex with Jan turturro in Korean
Irish girls bathroom and um didn't like
it I just what the hell and it's but
you're like their knee yeah I know all
use a horny and you're just like you're
halfway there use like I can't believe
it's like this guy have some kind of
ending and then we did it worse like
let's not say that that happened I'm
just like only all three of us got in
bed together and then went to sleep for
an hour and a half by then it was like
whatever 630 her alarm went off she had
to get up and go to work we had to go to
this like street festival thing so I'm
like all right I'm getting at I woke up
still drunk and I'm like I gotta go i'll
see you later i got dressed and left and
as I'm walking down the street i'm like
half a block away I just hear someone
yell my name and I look back I can't and
it is it's Jane torto it is I can see
you're running after you it's killing me
so no so she's coming after me and I was
like oh I look back and like not even
fully enough like Sonic the Hedgehog
through the crowd yeah that's her and
she goes she goes hey where are you
going and I'm like I'm going to the the
street fair and she goes where I'm she's
like as you somehow remembered this from
the night before she's like hey you're
staying over here that's right around
the corner from work I'm meeting up with
my friends let's walk together and I was
like oh I'm running late i'm actually
not going over there both lies yeah and
i start kind of just walking faster and
I'm like look I'm six foot four totally
able-bodied I'm ditching her and without
starting a run to me really make her
feel like [ __ ] so I start walking around
all cuts you can't make that leg right
yeah so Mike look there's a he'll take
that you know like like into this park
I'll walk up this and somewhat and I'm
looking back and she's actually like
gaining on me like I'm walking fast not
runnings not to be a dick and she's like
Mitt moving on me am I I didn't know she
had an interview it was like at the end
of the usual suspects violence Keyser
Soze starts to kind of straighten out a
walk normal that's what was kinda
happening and I was like dude she's
gaining on me and getting there and I
just I just ignored her and just kept
walking and I was like because literally
like it was it occurred to me as I was
doing it I'm like this I've had and
there was just that part of me that had
to get away we on a toilet laughs right
anything like I wasn't even able to
sleep it off and it just felt shitty
because it was like it was the it was
the first time like I've walked home
from one of those scenarios where the
shame followed yeah yeah I was like this
is I mean like that as far as walks of
shame go you know the shame never comes
with the way to manage a bird now I got
to my friends house [ __ ] and I was I'm
sorry i was on the street trying to get
to my friends house my other friend
yells out the door he's like hey dude
where you going I'm like oh what are you
doing here and he's like it were just
hanging out its own sales place and I
was like okay I walk up the stairs is it
get grab a beer the street fair is gonna
come through in a little bit hang out
we're hanging out on the staircase and
who comes up the staircase same friends
Jane turturro same friends same house no
I was like [ __ ] so like I can't shake
her she's like hey hey you trying to
[ __ ] that guy I've been trying to [ __ ]
him haven't try to fight they ever yeah
worse actually she followed me into the
kitchen she goes um she was so I'm
pregnant
oh my god I like know your stomach or
back to Jesus Christ like you get that
movement on your leg um so she goes on
you know they have a bathroom here too I
was like I gotta go and I just shy swear
to god she wanted to [ __ ] in that man
eight thirty in the morning and this
girls like let's [ __ ] in there about her
name no 830 yeah yeah some is korean
irish you'd been like yeah I bike
bathroom we're in a living room this is
just fine boom not my favorite threesome
story hands down so I just got the [ __ ]
out of there and I was like I'm going on
my friends house I'm gonna hide for a
while and then I called my buddy later
I'm like is she gone he's like yes she
left and then the day when I'm fine but
dude talk about trying I'm gonna have a
[ __ ] threesome and then it turns into
that ship first of all she made your
three men test without her you didn't
have any that's true no and I recognized
early but obviously you still would have
taken that girl home and had normal sex
with just her and not had to worry about
all the other all night yeah well there
was no I mean she was there and she
wasn't going anywhere I don't think Jan
helped I think that girl just was like
[ __ ] do this that's the thing that
she put herself in the scenario like to
tell me like hey it's either this
threesome or no I'm sitting here again
nothing so I had to work with right she
could have sabotaged it I had to work
with the animate you did you did the
right thing man sleeping with the enemy
yeah literally yeah no [ __ ] in a
bathroom on the toilet god damn yeah you
know have you kept up with the i love
them on facebook or anything
uh I later saw her on little people big
world though and I denied it oh come on
she's too big to be on the issue is
immoral for 10 man uh be a man that was
like that's a trip did it really was and
that's it all it's like you never tell
you can't tell sex stories if they're
just you seem like your bread then a
binge two hot girls that's one where
it's like what am i what did I get into
man I'll say what I got into that I'm
the Jan tutorials you what if it Jan to
throw shows up like this is your side oh
my god potential I don't even know what
I would do um so we were talking before
not come with the show ya novel was like
where I gotta find wood ah I won't hear
about this drug experience your first
time oh yeah this was also weirdly in
San Francisco I feel like you know san
Francisco has that feel that you want to
go do some fun go to shroom yeah and
I've like I've I've played the punch
line for so many years those are the
first road club that ever worked me so
I'd like Elliott the punchline October
2626 crap he's dead up in San Francisco
punch la that is also where my my album
1982 was recorded that's right at the
scene on Sacramento punch line where
we'll be on october 27 no not the
sacrament what was that again october
sacramento punch okay yeah no not that
is that the san francisco and where you
guys will be another october 26 I've
ever toys um yeah so yeah see I've
always I'd kind of gone up there at
least a couple times a year and then
I've had friends that live in the city
when you're up there in your early kind
of mid 20s that's when you're doing that
stuff anyway so I was performing at the
punch line this weekend and I'm not a
big like get drunk before the shows or
during the shows kind of guy so we
finished the Late Show at a bunch of
friends come out and like hey we're all
going up to the Tenderloin hit some bars
and I was like oh I can't wait you know
the late shows over I haven't really had
one beer so I'm like we racing this bar
have a shot and a beer and make them
here right away my buddy Tim never seen
anyone do the quick emergency mistaken
Cheeseman right yea big a Philly
cheesesteaks oh [ __ ] so he goes I'm like
I'm just trying to catch up you know
like I have some fun is that oh cool
well um we all just took ecstasy I'm
like I'm it man yeah but you know no
done that [ __ ] and like I wish is what I
literally all five of you and I'm the
only one still sober and he's like we'll
just do it I'm like they'd have never
done it and I don't know like I I'm just
I know about like drugs like I don't
know really what I'm getting is like
look you know you can trust me right I
was like I actually can like you're not
the kind of guy is gonna be like you
know here's an take this random stuff we
know the guy this now we've done it
before it's good clean Molly you know
it's not like this is all those other
[ __ ] in it you know oh there's that
dealer right here she's good people I
really wish I could remember to have
this happened after the threesome thing
I can't um but like I don't know if I
want the same time frame yes it like the
same couple years in a window so I mean
I don't know man he's like dude it'll be
cool and if anything happens I'm here
I've done this before like I got a clear
mind this isn't [ __ ] acid or anything
crazy like I'll take care of you feel
where anything else I'm like you know
what [ __ ] dude always wanted to try
it here's twenty bucks go get it for me
he walks off comes back with a pill I
just pop it in drink my beer I'm like
let's [ __ ] do it so bars closed is
like Nick stop yelling that song um we
get in a cab go to a house party 230 now
three we get there I'm like I'm not
really feeling it and I'm my mind this
entire time is like waiting for is am I
feeling it things feel good does it do I
feel like you know like light in my
floating I'm trying to like figure out
what's gonna happen nothing's happening
and I go hey man this shit's not kicking
his like will it take like a hit or two
a weed or something probably like help
jump starter to kind of heightened the
effects is what they say I'm like
I know they say all right take a hit
nothing really happens and I go dude
take it like a Duggars [ __ ] like just
kind of mild he's like um water Oh max
we all just took a second one and we're
pretty [ __ ] like we're rolling now
Mike did i just took my first one I'm
not doing this I know definitely do it
don't do the second one but we're
[ __ ] feeling real good right now Mike
[ __ ] does that talk to the guys and
we're all feeling pretty yeah because
you didn't feel left behind yet feel
left behind now man so then we get
kicked out of this guy's house like I
gotta go to bed you guys gotta go and
then while our other bodies having a
thing at his place we all go over there
and the cab is just like full appeal i
found more people this time but like he
kind of felt good that's like oh man it
feels like real warm in here he's like
yeah i think it started kicking him like
gonna be right like now he's got the
heat on the couch i was like sorry man
the heaters bridge is broken in the on
position so it's definitely not that
broken on yeah it's broken so it's like
yeah just like just let it happen
naturally dude I'm like all right so we
get to the house nothing and I'm like
can I drink is like no alcohol will
lessen the effect don't drink but then I
just got it my head that whiskey sounded
so good good like this just ecstasy
talking I'm like dude just let me have
my one shot is it no i'm likejust but
where's the bottle I'll just take like a
swig know your deli not handling it by
the bottle and I took a little sip
that's all you're getting and I was like
ah tasted so good though and I put it
back so then they're all outside kind of
like talking and hugging each other and
I'm just like standing in the kitchen
this one kind of like upset like
disappointed and then my friend comes in
and he's like hey man you are right I'm
like yeah I'm just gonna bomb this his
ecstasy is not working sucks and he's
like are you sure I'm like yeah why is
like you know you've been doing in here
for the past like 10 or 15 minutes we've
been watching from outside like what
he's like you've just been playing with
your zipper on your jacket just for 10
minutes just like up and down and then
it like occurred to me I was like I have
been and and the entire time I was doing
it I was just like feeling each tooth of
the zipper like I vibrate through my
body and thinking just how good it felt
and he's like that's the ecstasy dude
to working on my [ __ ] yet is with hugged
each other and he's like bemina time is
such a cool jacket I'm like I just got
it would you like to try it on and I
give it is like you try on my jacket
three other people can read is doing
we're trying on each other's jackets
like everything my god we also wearing
each other's jackets I there's like one
girl there and she's just like I wish I
could show like us on my jacket but I'm
so much smaller like it's cool you can
try on oars and jam pop tubs like you
try my only fits over my wrists again
right aha so we're doing that and then
this one dude walks in and he goes off
what are you guys doing like all caddy
and weird and were like uh we're just
trying on to this jacket see what's
going on he's like you guys are being
weird or like did I don't think we are
we be weird or words were somehow like
how beautiful everyone's clothing is how
like amazing we all are as people and
he's like what's up with you guys like
war on ecstasy and he's like oh well
that's why you're acting I'm not on
ecstasy at all we're like okay we're
like sorry man what was your name again
and we kind of like all introduce
ourselves to him and stuff and then he
was like um he said I still think you
guys are acting weird towards me were
like why why would you think that it's
like because I'm I'm gay and I'm black
and people generally mistreat me because
of that and I think you guys are doing
that and we're like what you guys think
you think that we're all racist
homophobes none of us are like this one
white person the rest of us are other
stuff and they all live in San Francisco
one of the most liberal cities in
America and we're all on a drug that
makes us feel only love I just found a
beauty of a zipper right yeah and you
think we hate you because you're a black
a guy and he goes yeah I like you need
to do ecstasy out of everyone in here
using I don't do those drugs I'm like
well you should start dude because what
you're saying makes no sound all we feel
is just like pure love right now and if
anything you're kind of getting in the
way of that so we like we went outside
smoking cigarettes which tastes
so amazing when you're on ecstasy and
then I got my head I wanted more whiskey
liqueur that whiskey ever that you can
have any and I just I wouldn't let it go
and I took a sip of it and it it tasted
like someone melted jolly ranchers in a
bottle and I just like capped go and he
just took it from me and I was like this
is really starting to kick in during it
oh yeah it was it was amazing and we go
back into the kitchen and then the the
the gay black guys arguing with the one
girl and he came wouldn't let it go is
it is that why are all these people
being so homophobic and racist and she's
like honey you have to understand that
all we are experiencing is love in the
universe and you need to be a part of
that and is a don't pressure me into
doing drugs and he wouldn't let it go
and then we went back outside and while
I dude what's that guy's problem like i
don't know and then she wouldn't even
know that guy like who'd why'd you guys
invite him were like we don't know that
guy like wait who is this guy no one and
no one knew who he was he happened to be
at the other party and while he was at
the other party and he got in the cow
that's the guy I got the cab he pry
hailed the cab but yeah yeah but all
these people yeah right so we go well
maybe he was friends with the guy lived
at the other house and then just jumped
in with us and I was like I'll go
investigate and I went as a hey man yes
we're having a good time Bubba so you
feel this way but we're just having fun
who's his friends whose friend are you
again and he's like uh is it honor
really know anyone here like us you must
embodies with food John's plays whereas
like no no we were all at the bar
together and you guys are just got much
cabs and I just asked if I could go with
you guys because I heard you say you're
gonna house party and he just like was
at the bar and just jumped in the car
and just a none of us noticed because
we're all just like looking good
everybody's well yeah so we were like he
was not kind of starting like weird us
out cuz when none of us is just some
random dude is starting to get
increasingly more upset with how racist
and homophobic he thinks he is we all
are as we're on like the a drug that
makes you feel only love and only
recognize the beauty in the world and
we're like we gotta get the [ __ ] out
here so the guy who lives at this place
because guys it's like 530 sounds coming
home I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
and we're like all right um we got to
formulate a plan
um we can't call a cab because I'll just
show up and he'll want to get in and
that's his whole thing yeah right yeah
he'll already be outside he'll he'll see
he'll he'll know that the the numbers of
the cab Rhode Island I'll just wait out
the partner and the driveway so we're
like all right there's gonna be a bus
coming at the end of this street at like
615 or whatever um we're all gonna walk
down there but we're gonna leave in like
segments you know so he won't really
notice and then we'll just meet at the
corner get on this bus and then take off
so two people walk out first he doesn't
even notice and then two more leave me
and me and my buddy and then the girl
ends up staying behind just to kind of
[ __ ] with him and uh and then catch
up with us so she leaves and she goes I
gotta go to the bathroom I'll be right
back so she walks out the front door he
now gets it he's like I don't see
anybody anywhere he opens the front door
and sees us all walking down the street
yeah you pulled it off right well yeah
we got away and we look back where are
you guys going and we're like [ __ ] just
keep walking like he didn't hear him
know we're coming we're still moving and
then he starts walking faster and then
we start walking faster he's like are
you guys trying to leave without me
that's [ __ ] up [ __ ] know this dude
and now it's a bit feels like we're
betraying him bucking leaving them and
we're like if we start running now we'll
probably get to the corner by the time
that bus shows up and we'll get on it
and ba believe because he's like half a
block away at that point we're like on
three everyone run one two three and we
all just [ __ ] took off and like like
the toxic on timing or like in a movie
right is we're getting to the street
corner this bus just appears out of
nowhere stops we all run in run on get
to the back window and look out and he's
running after us like the bus started
moving at this point and all we could
hear him say was just yellow the address
and I'll meet you there no he didn't I
swear to God I sorta got it
dude I I don't know anyone who's never
needed more friends than that meri jan 2
door oh man Jay Jay yeah I know yeah you
would be a perfect I hope that they met
somewhere in San Francisco they hit it
off and just became best friends because
they clearly needed other people we went
back to my friends my it's just we
couldn't believe was like how that like
did you really think we were just gonna
yell the address they were clearly
running away from you and then we all
kind of like kick back at the place like
how this has been a great night minus
that dude how do we end it we rolled a
couple joints he had a bong packed a
bowl and then we're looking through
stuff to watch and we found Nirvana's
unplugged and then put that on smoked a
bunch of weed and just watch that man
who sold the world man yeah we are we
all fell asleep till is ending woke up
the next morning because it was it was
like pure Molly I get that hangover when
we woke up the next morning but this is
like 630 in the morning well I like at
noon or whatever but woke the next at
noon I just will open my eyes as if
nothing as if I didn't take any drug and
I was just like as if you weren't a
homophobic race as if I was the person I
knew I really wasn't outside and I just
like I woke up and I like a part of it
felt like a dream and then I realized it
wasn't now just like those are the most
pleasurable experiences I've ever had in
my life and since then I've just
everyone i know that has never done a
sound like do it get pure Molly go with
some friends and just have a [ __ ] up
have a blast cuz it's so much fun yeah
but make sure it's like puri not laced
with other [ __ ] right but dude well
we're there man this has been a lot of
fun this has been a lot of fun so much
fun ah thank you for being here thank
you for having me again and we want more
time promote your album your your social
media whatever you want ah the Oddcast
oh yeah the podcast i forgot to mention
on all things calmly network that we're
on right now yeah I'm the fantastic all
things comedy network it's called
occasionally awesome Kevin Christy and I
and episodes are well occasionally they
are occasionally awesome so yeah you can
hear that on all things comedy itunes
you know all the places are the album is
called
nineteen eighty-two it's available
digitally everywhere and then vinyl soon
and then social media instagram twitter
snapchat Facebook all of that is Nick
Youssef ni ckyo us SEF and Nikki SEF
calm for Road dates and all those other
things that's it oh man it's always
great to have you on thank you so much
fun this is such a fun this is this such
a fun podcast so thank as always Jay
Larson calm be calm Jay Larson comedy on
all social media Ryan Sickler calm Ryan
Sickler on all social media will talk to
y'all next Tuesday